I was a big dairy queen kid not a true
Texan if you haven't had water burgers
we are here in one of the greatest
cities in the world
Austin Texas and my hometown to try what
a burger why burger was started in
Corpus Christi in 1950 and since then
it's dominated the Texas fast food
culture how often do you water burger
every Saturday every Saturday had our
family Thanksgivings at Whataburger a
couple times so we are here to see what
the fuss is all about
so I sent a message to all my Facebook
fans asking what I should get let's do
to the paddy mouths to honey butter
let's do the chicken strips
that was just my order we have to get
prints we just ordered fifty five
dollars worth of food just by pure
weight to text this way we should call
Quinta oh yeah she's had water burger
before probably not have you ever heard
of water burger unlike some of the other
fast-food restaurants and they never
made it to ordered it that's why we used
to always eat here when I was little
because it was always fresh okay guys
make sure you have a doctor nearby the
burgers are cute why didn't fly yeah
like Texas you have to hold this with
two hands it's so big I love it some
people might describe as like buttery
some might describe it as grill the
mustards really weird to like fight into
unasked-for this is way better than
McDonald's
tastes like Burger King to me with like
jalapeno this is the furthest away from
a garden and the closest you can get to
a slaughterhouse I give this one me huh
there's no Yi and how about if I had to
compare this to a Texas born celebrity
definitely Michelle Rodriguez this is
fast and experience and probably exit me
past injuries so patty knows and that
toast though actually says that a lot of
her followers said that this was like
one of the must-haves I don't even like
burgers and it takes more home cook than
any other fast food that I've had
anything on Texas toast and then just
like a [ __ ] ton of me and it's good I
feel cheated because this is way better
than Dairy Queen I would give this three
Huss what celebrity is this this is
definitely a Gomez this how you belt can
get it just like Selena Gomez I've seen
Eugene drunk and the man can put away so
much better
what a chicken what a chicken why isn't
everything come with a side of white
gravy
everybody said chicken tenders with
gravy that's a good batter that's like a
well spiced chicken a little kick us out
a bit I gave it to Edie Hawes it's like
perfectly acceptable but relatively
bland it was like the Owen Wilson thing
whatever girl I could drink this like
the gravy is delicious true fries never
leave unattended they're funny at
whatever yeah and spicy ketchup when I
go to Korean restaurants I always judge
a restaurant by their kimchi and was
best we always judge it by the fries
surprised very mediocre at such high
expectations for these fries oh so these
are like Lance Armstrong honestly I'm
trying spicing it up
mmm oh hell yeah well caters everything
like sweet and sour sauce and ketchup
how to fake as I go sir Roger place I
would give this horny hog I think my
skin is getting greasy ER by the second
oh yes whooping honey look I've never
seen anything like this
at a fast-food establishment oh my god
is just oozing just buttery goodness
it's a sexy looking piece of me
you come to Texas just that you can eat
this this is the Beyonce of Whataburger
Ida my god it's so good at melting Ralph
this is like 7:00 yeehaw out of a one to
five scale I have the biggest food boner
right now it's that gross is that Chris
hurry Ashley overall I understand why
people love Whataburger it made me say
what a good ass burger it's like very
Texas though there's like so much flavor
package everything everything is way too
big this is a medium you can take the
boy out of Texas but you can't take the
Texas out of the boy maybe you'd like
Mary in and out but what a burger you
would just have sex with whatever hurt
like every night do I keep making feed
the sex I'm sorry my skin is already
terrible from eating like to thank you
jeans fine he's shaking a little part of
it